an
asteroid races toward earth it's big
it's fast and it's about to do a lot of
damage
[Music]
but we're not just gonna sit around and
wait for the end of days
we're going to fight back
[Music]
what would happen if we nuked an
asteroid
would it save humanity or make things
worse
how does a nuclear blast in space
compare to a blast on earth
and would our nukes even be strong
enough to destroy it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we nuked an asteroid
in the year 2175 the asteroid
bennu will pass by earth and there's a 1
in 2700 chance that it will hit us
if those sound like good odds to you
think again
bennu is taller than the empire state
building and
it's 15 times heavier than the great
pyramid of giza
and if it hit the earth it would release
as much energy
as 23 sarbambas which
is the largest hydrogen bomb ever
exploded
do you still like those odds i'd like
them a little more if we had a
contingency plan
for nasa that's the hypervelocity
asteroid mitigation mission for
emergency response
also known as hammer and just like its
name suggests
the plan is to ram into an incoming
asteroid or to detonate a nuke that will
send it off course
but will it be enough and
what sort of repercussions could we
expect
the sooner we discover an asteroid
heading our way the safer will be
for example if we detected an incoming
asteroid
a year in advance we'd only have to
change its course by
a few centimeters to keep it from
hitting earth
to do this we could detonate a nuclear
bomb a few hundred meters away from the
asteroid
causing it to change its course and move
away from earth
and if that didn't work we could just
crash into the asteroid with
the most powerful bomb we've got
but if anything were to malfunction
before the bomb reached the asteroid
the resulting consequences might even be
worse
than the asteroid hitting earth but
once the nuke was in space the world's
population would be
relatively safe with no atmosphere out
there
only vacuum the blast would disappear
completely
but the radiation would be much stronger
while people on earth would be safe
anyone in
any nearby spaceships would be risking
their lives
in the interest of preventing as many
casualties as possible
this would have to be an automated
mission and
assuming that nothing goes wrong and
there isn't some kind of
ai mutiny we could very well succeed
in pushing an asteroid off course
as long as it wasn't too big
a bigger asteroid would require bolder
tactics
such as dart dart stands for double
asteroid redirection test
nasa plans to slam into an asteroid in
2022 to change its orbit
the impact would be equal to three tons
of tnt
this mission could result in the first
ever man-made
meteorite shower and if it works it will
serve as a blueprint of how we could
respond to asteroid threats in the
future
of course when it comes to destroying
bennu the bomb we'll use will be at
least
a million times stronger than what dart
will be packing
and yes we've got nukes that are that
powerful
the only thing we'd have to look out for
after blowing up a giant asteroid
is space debris the debris could
severely damage our satellites and
endanger any astronauts aboard the
international space station
and if any larger chunks of the asteroid
found their way down to
earth they could create craters up to
20 times their size
on the bright side if the nuke exploded
close enough to earth
the radiation it emits would be
distorted by our planet's
magnetic field which would probably be
the prettiest light show
you'd ever see
[Music]
or if you don't want to wait for a
doomsday scenario you could just take a
trip up north
to see the northern lights it's crazy to
think that
nuking asteroids is a potential survival
plan for humanity but
considering it's us against well pretty
much
anything in the infinite void of space
we have to make do with what we have
have you ever thought about how you
would survive a solar storm
find out what we'd do by checking out
our new show
how to survive
[Music]